GEORGIA EACH HAVE ONE
CORONAVIRUS DEATH EACH.
TUCKER?
>> Tucker: TRACE GALLAGHER,
THANKS FOR THAT.
THE GLOBAL DEATH TOTAL OF THE
CHINESE CORONAVIRUS IT’S AT
ALMOST 5,000 PEOPLE, THAT’S THE
OFFICIAL NUMBER.
IN IRAN, THE OFFICIALS HAVE NOT
EVEN COME FROM THE TOTAL OF 500
DEATHS, THAT’S WHAT THEY ARE
CLAIMING.
SATELLITE IMAGES SUGGEST THAT
AUTHORITIES ARE MAKING MASSIVE
CHANGES THERE TO HOLD MASSIVE
VICTIMS, BUT THEY ARE THE ONLY
PEOPLE WHO LIVE.
NEVER FORGET HOW WE GOT HERE FOR
THIS PANDEMIC CAME OUT OF CHINA
AND IT CAME OUT OF CHINA FOR A
REASON, IT’S 8TH DOWN THE
COUNTRY WITH POOR HEALTH
PRACTICES,
IT COULD HAVE STOPPED BEFORE IT
SPREAD OUT OF CONTROL.
THE OUTBREAK MAY HAVE BEGUN NOT
IN A PUBLIC MEAT MARKET BUT IN A
POORLY LUNCH CHINESE LABORATORY.
THAT IS NOT OUR THEORY, ANYBODY
WHO RAISES THE THEORY IS A
CONSPIRACY MONGER!
BUT THIS IS NOW THE THEORY
COMING FROM A NOW CENSORED
CHINESE PAPER.
A DRAFT PAPER, SCIENTISTS AT THE
SOUTH
BEGAN AT THE WUHAN CENTERS FOR
DISEASE CONTROL WHERE THE ANIMAL
MAY HAVE INFECTED A RESEARCHER
WHO THEN SPREAD THE DISEASE
OUTSIDE THE FACILITY.
THE PAPER IS EXPLICIT ABOUT
THIS.
WE ARE GOING TO QUOTE IT.
THE KILLER CORONAVIRUS PROBABLY
ORIGINATED FROM A LABORATORY IN
WUHAN."
WE HAVE NO IDEA IF THAT’S
ACTUALLY TRUE.
BUT AGAIN, THOSE ARE CHINESE
RESEARCHERS MAKING
EVIDENCE-BASED ARGUMENTS ABOUT
THE ORIGIN OF THIS VIRUS, THAT
THEY’VE SINCE BEEN TAKEN DOWN,
THE EXPLANATION HAS BEEN OFFERED
THAT YOU CAN GET.
CHINA, THE SAME COUNTRY THAT
CONTROLS 96% OF ANTIBIOTICS WE
USE IN THIS NATION, THE SAME
COUNTRY THAT’S WANTING TO CUT
OFF DRUG EXPORT TO THE U.S. TO
KILL AMERICANS, IS NOW TRYING TO
HIDE THE REALITY OF WHERE
CORONAVIRUS CAME FROM.
IN FACT, THEY ARE DOING WORSE
THAN THAT.
THE COMMUNIST PARTY OF CHINA IS
TRYING TO BLAME THE VIRUS ON
AMERICA.
A WEEK AGO, ATTACK ANYONE WHO
DARED TO LINK THE VIRUS TO CHINA
CHINA.
>> CERTAIN MEDIA SAYS THIS
CORONAVIRUS IS A CHINA VIRUS,
THIS IS EXTREMELY IRRESPONSIBLE
AND WE FIRMLY OPPOSE THAT.
WE ARE STILL TRACING THE ORIGIN
OF THE VIRUS AND THERE IS NO
CONCLUSION YET.
>> Tucker: THAT WAS LAST WEEK.
HAS EVOLVED SINCE THEN.
TODAY ON TWITTER, HE ACCUSED
AMERICA OF CREATING THE VIRUS.
"WHEN THE PATIENT ZERO BEGINNING
IN THE U.S.?
HOW MANY PEOPLE WERE INFECTED,
WHAT ARE THE NAMES OF THE
HOSPITALS?
IT MIGHT BE THE U.S. ARMY THAT
BROUGHT THE EPIDEMIC TO WUHAN.
THE U.S. OWES US NEXT DONATION.
EXCLAMATION POINT.
KEEP IN MIND, THE CHINESE
LEADERSHIP THAT THE MEDIA CLASS
HAS SUCKED UP TO, EVEN WHEN
CHINA BLAMED THE UNITED STATES
FOR A PLAGUE THEY UNLEASHED,
EVEN WHEN THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT
THREATENED TO MURDER OUR
CITIZENS BY CUTTING OFF DRUGS,
OUR MEDIA CONTINUE TO TAKE THEIR
SIDE.
WATCH THIS.
>> THE PRESIDENT REFERRED TO THE
CORONAVIRUS AS A FOREIGN VIRUS
AND I THINK IT’S GOING TO COME
ACROSS TO A LOT OF AMERICANS AS
MAKING OF XENOPHOBIA.
>> Tucker: THAT WAS CNN’S JIM
ACOSTA, A POISONOUS.
AMAZINGLY, THOUGH, IT WAS JUST A
FEW MONTHS AGO, THAT ACOSTA WAS
SENDING TWEETS HIMSELF ABOUT THE
"WUHAN CORONAVIRUS.
HE RECEIVED HIS ORDERS FROM JEFF
ZUCKER HE RECEIVES HIS ORDERS
FROM CHINA, SO THAT’S OKAY.
BUT THE WORD IS OUT.
MUST PROTECT CHINA AT ALL COSTS,
EVEN RESIDENTIAL CANDIDATES ARE
PLAYING ALONG.
>> DOWNPLAYING IT, OVERLY
DISMISSIVE, IT’S ONLY GOING TO
HURT US AND FURTHER ADVANTAGE
THE SPREAD OF THE DISEASE.
BUT NEITHER SHOULD WE PANIC OR
FALL BACK ON XENOPHOBIA,
LABELING COVID-19 A FOREIGN
VIRUS DOES NOT DISPLACE
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR MISS DELMAN
JUDGMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN TAKEN
SO FAR BY ITS ADMINISTRATION.
>> Tucker: SO IT’S OUR FAULT.
JUST TO BE CLEAR, DESCRIBING A
VIRUS FROM WUHAN AS THE WUHAN
VIRUS IS NOT XENOPHOBIA, ITS
ACCURACY AND ANYBODY WHO SAYS
OTHERWISE IS LYING AND PROBABLY
FOR A REASON.
THE GOVERNMENT’S CHIEF
OBLIGATION IS TO THE LIVE OF OUR
CITIZENS.
IT’S NOT TO OTHER COUNTRIES,
IT’S NOT TO THE GEP, AS NOT TO
THE COMMONEST PARTY OF CHINA.